in case you haven't noticed I am still
capable Giacometti and I will talk about
audio analysis now why is this
interesting what kind of application
could we have so some examples but to
feel this way broader than Allah I'm
representing it here we can have
information that revolve from audio
either music or speech or it could also
it could also be very useful in an
industrial setting so for example
looking for faults in gearboxes or
things like that
we could do speech analysis we could use
all of the machine learning
functionality that we have on the result
of this analysis and many more limited
by your imagination essentially so I was
going to go through this again
there our basic concepts most of you
were here already so I will go through
them quickly but yeah so three sounds a
harmonic sound in harmonic sound
impulsive sound a function for plotting
them a function for visualizing the
power spectrum and something in between
something that has both time information
and frequency information okay so this
is our general premise as usual now
let's go and let's see what we have so I
will load up again here our nice drum
loop that you have listened to and I'm
going to introduce our first function
for today all your measurements so this
function does different kind of
measurements and they are computed on
all the signal so all the values are
part of this computation so let's see
what properties we have by the way I
should say I am using now 11-point line
so there are some properties here that
will not show up in 11 the notebook
that's online will have
version with the proper implementation
411 that's cheating
so we have as you can see we have a lot
of a long list of properties we have
some of the more boring one like how
many channels this audio has what kind
of audio type is this audio but then it
can get more interesting than that so I
divided here this big list of properties
into time domain properties which have
computed on the actual sample values and
frequency domain path properties which
are computed on either the power
spectrum or the magnitude magnitude
spectrum of the signal so what are these
time domain properties another big list
that is not evaluating okay here we go
so I will show some example of those I
will show the first of all the most
basic ones by the way do notice how
nicely they come out formatted in a
beautiful data set so these are very
simple ones we have the main max mean
standard deviation RMS amplitude the
number of zero crossings in the signal
this fairly useful properties but you
have to keep in mind that many of these
results you can also get by applying
their corresponding statistical function
directly onto the other object which is
fairly exciting I can do standard
deviation of my audio signal and this
just gives me that correct result and
here we go I am computing exactly the
same properties but by using the
statistical functions now you will
notice that means some there are some
discrepancies between the two results
there is a fundamental difference
between the implementation of audio
measurements and statistical functions
they they get the same result but they
kind of could have different users so
audio measurements
operates on the down next version of the
signal while the corresponding function
operates and start on the flattened
version of the data to explain what it
does I have this is the data that
corresponds to a two channel audio
signal I can have the min/max of this
audio signal and as you can see it's
equivalent to having the min/max applied
to the flattened version of the data if
I instead use all your measurements this
is equivalent to applying the function
to the mean of the data so this is a
very small detail but it's something to
be aware to avoid incurring into
perplexing situations in addition to all
of the statistical properties that we
have here in other measurements like
standard deviation and total and etc etc
there are a lot more statistical
functions that can be applied directly
to audio have some examples at the
moment the second movement the quantile
or even the entropy if we want so now
let's go into the frequency domain
properties that's working again our nice
list so all of these have to do with
where the energy is located in the
spectrum so it could have for example
spectral Center it gives us an idea
where the center of the centroid of this
distribution is it's a very good measure
if we want to see if we have a sound as
predominantly heavy in the base
frequencies or in the high frequency
this is a very light to compute and
useful measurement but we also have
things like spectral all of which gives
an idea of where most of the energy is
located this tells us was the frequency
frequency under which 95% of the energy
of the signal is contained and and so on
and so on we can have statistical
properties of the spectrum like kurtosis
and flat
and sorry skewness and so just to show
you some example with this measurements
I know that the the centroid of the
spectral distribution is around 700
Hertz I know that it is fairly flat
which which tells me that it will be
fairly spread out most of the energy is
underneath 300 Hertz and the spread of
this though is very wide now what is an
example application of this global
measurements which sound sound pretty
dry in themselves now here I have a list
of all the objects each has some drum
head this is a essentially partitioned
version of the drum signal that we were
listening to so it is a small segment of
those what I can do is just compute the
spectral centroid and spread on all of
these all the objects and I can just
find the clusters in these measurements
I could plot them with less line plot
using the actual audio objects as plot
markers I can see we can find four
different clusters let's see what they
are this lower one seems to have all of
those seem to have a snare sound in them
this one fairly consistent we have a
kick done into them and this one's a
most simple heavy than the other ones so
this is a fantastic thing about
integration we devolve from language we
can do whatever analysis we want and
then we can just feed those assaults
into any of the for example machine
learning functionality that we have know
a different take on measurements is
computing local fish features instead of
figure out some property on a global
scale we can partition the signal and
compute the value of the property per
each partition and this is what audio
local measurement does so the input is
not the object and
result is the time series and the time
stamp of each value corresponds to the
center of the partition so let's look at
the RMS amplitude of our signal it is
nice time series and we can easily
superimpose it to the plot of the
waveform here we go now how do we
control the partitioning of because the
partitioning scheme here is extremely
important in the quality and efficiency
all the measurements so we do have all
your local measurement has a partition
granularity argument and we can control
partition size offset and a window
function that will be applied to the
data before the measurement is performed
so nice to find those and here worth the
measurement is computer this is kind of
a visual I don't know if it is a bit too
small this is a kind of visual take on
how the signal is partitioned you can
see this is the size of the partition
and of course the difference the
difference in times between the
beginning of one partition next one is
the offset and we can specify those
either as numbers that will be done
interpreted as amount in seconds but we
can specify also as quantities and we
take any any kind of quantity that
represents time but we could also if we
want to do something more precise in
terms of locations we could specify
amounts in samples and here we go same
kind of result so the other convenient
thing is that we can query for multiple
properties at once that's just a terms
an association this is very convenient
for visually visualizing as well with
automatic labels okay so now now that we
have an idea of the basic structure of
the function what can we do with it what
properties can we compute
this is an even longer list and I will
divide it again into time domain
properties and frequency domain
properties so now I will use from now on
this this bit of recording it's just a
female voice hello hello hello so this
is the list of time domain properties
some of them in 11.1 still experimental
like I'll like for months for example so
those will not be present in the in the
notebook online so let's see how some of
them work so here I am asking for some
of the basic properties that we looked
at with other measurements that are
termed are simply a list of numbers here
we get a more complete information we
can see the minimum mean max and
standard deviation of the signal as the
signal evolve so most of them many of
these property at this time domain
properties are analogous to them and
they global properties that we looked at
before but there are some new ones that
are fairly interesting so very important
one is it's called LPC which are which
stands for dinner prediction
coefficients so I take a list of data
and I want to find the coefficients that
give us the best finite difference
approximation of the signal so here I am
asking for 46 officiants usually in
literature this is kind of one of those
magic numbers it is computed starting
from the sampling frequency of the audio
but it is no one really tries to explain
why so there's one of those magic
numbers that we all have to deal with
super each partition this will return
back at time series whose value is a
factor of 46 numbers we could for
example blot that very easily with the
right plot and here we have our LPC
analysis
the signal linear prediction coefficient
Yamaha
another extremely interesting property
that will be very important in low-level
speech analysis is position informants
so the formants are the resonances of
your vocal tract and the position of
these resonances are very much linked to
which vocalic sound you are pronouncing
so here we go
Here I am computing I am asking for only
two four months
this is to four months is something that
allows us already to figure out which
kind of vocalic sound a person is is
emitting and Here I am clipping the say
I am multiplying the signal by the RMS
amplitude clipped and rounded so that
whenever the amplitude of the signal is
below a threshold we don't see any
signal because I mean a measurement of
four months on a noisy signal that's
that's that doesn't have any voice in it
is kind of meaningless and here we go
you can see this is the blue line is the
first formant and the yellow line is the
second firm and you can see one goes
down and one goes up this is the
responsive sound the E and O sounds so
frequency domain properties that we can
compute these all have very obscure
names the first one that I wanted to
show you is the M FCC is that that
stands for low frequencies AppStore
coefficients so the whole idea behind
this kind of measurements is when we
look at the spectrum of something the
frequency axis is linear but how we
perceive it it is definitely not linear
we perceive
what is called pitch of a sound which
has a nonlinear relationship to
frequency so we for example a small
change of in frequency applaude
frequency has a dramatic effect as a
mole change in frequency at high
frequency has little to no effect in our
perception so what this kind of
measurement does is tries to provide to
some information that has this kind of
response let's say so it is weighted on
human perception essentially and as an
LPC it does return us per each partition
a list of values in this specific case
13 the first of which is usually
discarded so let's look at the plot of
this and fantastic that was one too much
sorry about that this is more like it
so as you can see it's a similar signal
to the LPC measurement that we looked at
before this is something that
understandably used in speech
recognition argument another very
important perceptual measurement is the
fundamental frequency always talking
about pitch so when you listen to a
sound you can immediately tell this if
or if you compare different sounds you
can immediately tell the picture of this
one is higher the pitch of this other
one is lower but the final pitch for
machine is kind of complicated which is
a perceptual quantity we cannot look at
the spectrum and find the highest peak
and say that's the pitch the pitch of
the sound I showed before harmonic
sounds have the whole collection of
Peaks and it is not necessarily true
that the highest one of them are the
lowest in frequency of them corresponds
to the fundamental frequency so with
fundamental frequency property we try to
kind of take care of this difficulty and
return
the fundamental frequency for whatever
sound keep in mind that this kind of
fundamental frequency is defined for
monophonic sounds so if for example if
you have a piano that plays two sons at
a time this is something our function
fundamental frequency cannot deal with
this is that is a very difficult problem
that will be touch will be tackled
eventually now there are some other
interesting properties here that instead
of being computed on a single partition
of the signal of comparing a partition
to the previous one so we want and all
of these deal with change as a function
of time so these are some of the most
important ones high frequency content
novelty a distance between specter of
frames a phase deviation from the
measured phase and the predictor phase a
distance in the complex domain this is
the most of these act on the Fourier
transform of the partition all of these
active the fugitives are on the
partition server then so let's look at
what they tell us so let's remember what
we we do have our we do how let me
reevaluate the properties because that's
random we do have our spoken signal here
what all of these measurements can tell
us is when new things happen or when
transient events happen and
high-frequency content is the dumbest
one I would say but all the other ones
look at changes in the spectral domain
the complex spectral domain from
partition to partition and they have
different reasons to exist but they all
try to measure the amount of change as a
function of time essentially I'll have
an example later to show an application
of this one
now another important analysis function
is interval detection so the whole idea
is please do remember all the properties
that we were looking at for our local
measurements now any of these can be
part of a cry use of the final tier
criterion so for example here I am
looking for whenever the RMS amplitude
is less than point zero three with all
your intervals I get a list of intervals
where this property is satisfied I can
easily visualize it like this and in
this case what I was looking for was
bits of silence well they're a mess
amplitude is low we are fairly sure that
that silence and the nice integration
between this function means that I can
just say audio delete those intervals
and let me plane ignore our perfect
timing voice and now all the solid
interval takes time I've deleted you can
see it here now the nice thing is that
this criterion is not limited to a
single property we can have a criterion
defined by multiple properties and logic
statements as well so I'll take a bit
more compute in this case I asked and so
here I am analyzing this sample which is
a flute scale
I will leave it at this that's not
particularly more interesting than that
I am asking where the amplitude is less
than point no more than point one so
when there is some signal and when the
fundamental frequency is less than
something or more than something else
and I can easily find that so this is
lower than our first threshold and only
these two are higher than our threshold
and this is easily shown with this
spectrum as you can see this is lower
than 270 these are in our Forbidden Zone
and these are higher a more general in
function that's very much related to all
your measurements is audio block map
here the idea is that instead of nothing
and measure a predefined measurements on
the partition signal the user is able to
define whatever function to be computed
onto the partition signal so here this
is the dumbest example here I'm asking
just for max to be mapped on each
partition this is completely equivalent
to what audio local measurements max
property does and I get my nice signal
now it is possible to define more
interesting function and in this case I
am working for the RMS amplitude and I
am taking the logarithm of it so I get
the value of the MS amplitude in
decibels and here we go
but we are not limited to numbers we can
have lists of numbers in this example I
am for each for each partition I am
grabbing the maximum value of the
partition and I am I am creating a disk
where the size of the disk and the color
the hue of discs are controlled by this
maximum value so I can get fairly nice
visualization of the maximum amplitude
as the function of time here both the
color and the size of the disk tell us
some information about it of course I
could have different functions map to
the color and size
now let's have let's go to the more
interesting pub some example
applications now here I have I am
importing all the example data
collection for audio let me give you a
list of what's present these are all
they're all the sample all the sounds
that we all do do recordings that we
have collected and shipped with
Mathematica and with this come on here I
am computing the LPC property that we
discussed before I am computing that on
each single of these ones what I can do
is I can compute the distance matrix of
the measurement there each recording
thus creating kind of a unique signature
for each of of the sample sounds that we
do have this might take a bit to
evaluate but the result is very pretty
hopefully
it is a bit of graphics to compute and
display here we go so each one of them
has a very unique pattern that emerges
from this kind of computation this could
be for example used as a signature for
an audio object to measure distances
from one audio object to another or to
recognize what so for example just to
give you a simple explanation you can
see within the collection we have a big
list of impulse responses stir and as
you can see all the impulse responses
have an extremely similar structure but
I could look at the flute scale here and
I can see the destruction of the piano
scale is also very close to it so there
is a lot of that can be done in this
regard LPC properties can also be used
in this kind of setting now let's look
at yes yes so they are all square
because each partition is compared to
any other partition so each one is
unique to one audio object okay and each
partition in the Saudi object is
compared to each other partition so the
resulting the graphics is always a
square so let's look at the MAL
frequency sap stock components here I
have four different equivalents of the
same sentence it's the Alice was
beginning to get very tired of sitting
by her sister Alice was beginning to get
very tired of sitting by her it's the
same first sentence of Alice in
Wonderland we can look at them and we
can compute the EM FCC property on them
and was visualized it and having this
collection of msec properties for each
recording we can compute a distance
matrix between the four requirements we
can go further though we can compute the
working correspondence between two of
them by using dynamic time warping so
what we can what we get as a result is a
plot that tells us that does the dynamic
time warping of the timing aspect of one
of the audio objects with respect to the
other okay I promised that I would talk
about transient detection I will go
through this very quickly I have here
yes
so speech recognition is something that
is being developed in parallel to the
audio capabilities and I assume that
will be absolutely no effort they
recognize the speech no effort in
recognizing speech so you mean
translation between recording and text
this is what you're saying yes so that
is one of the things that is being
developed in parallel with all these and
all these features yes well not in audio
it will be a separate function I assume
this is something I don't know but all
yes generally no better or tamati
actually
sorry there so there are two approaches
this the approach of speech recognizer
is based on machine learning and neural
networks but you can have a much lower
level approach that is based on formant
analysis and this kind of thing and long
time a lot of similar technologies to
formant analysis that is well if you let
me show you yes yes so let me give you
one example of the basic thing that that
is underlining all of this so I talked
before about firmance is the residence
is a your vocal tract that okay there
related to what which vowel you are
speaking so here I have a list of
different vowels so the usual
representation of the vowel triangle
even though is the trapezoid is
something like this and I could easily
just use the formants measurements to
reproduce exactly the same vowel
triangle and here I have it plotted will
so in this K and or if I have my female
voice example that I played before
I just I just get up from Wikipedia the
average locations of deferment and I can
map I can compare the result of the
measurement with the nearest function
and I get which kind of vowels are
spoken as a function of time and as you
can see there is a sound close to be and
then sound close to oh and oh there are
very much the building blocks of what
hello is so yes we are trying to build
you are trying to make the main building
blocks that will be necessary for this
kind of analysis you might I don't think
I have any more time I is there any time
for questions no okay
well if you have any questions I will be
here thank you